6 47. now yesterday you didn't really
need your sunglasses
we had so many uh clouds around but this
morning that's a different story look at
the reflection there of
some of the hotel properties on the
strip so good sunshine this morning
a few clouds off to the east but the sun
has pretty much cleared those clouds now
lots of 80s around the valley 79 at
mountains edge
71 at red rock but the dew points are
still high that's telus
tells us there's still plenty of monsoon
moisture out there we kind of got
missed with the rain yesterday had a few
sprinkles around the valley
some isolated thunderstorms in clark
county and
areas of northwest arizona again some
pretty good thunderstorms all around
kingman and riding right up into utah up
into esmeralda and nye counties
yesterday
kind of the spots that we were expecting
thunderstorms to focus on
today only about a 10 percent chance but
that monsoon pattern is still
set up it's not going anywhere there's
just not a lot of energy not a lot of
impulses
to trigger any big thunderstorms today
so
the focus will be on the mountains with
about a 30 chance you get that lift
going
and that's where we get the greater
chance in the mountains about 80
degrees for a high up there a little
warmer for us today without those clouds
out there we
expect to reach a high of about 105 with
just a very slight chance
of some isolated thunderstorms sometimes
it's days like today
you have to really be on guard because
we kind of let our guard down and then
we can get caught
with an isolated storm that produces
some good rain or some vivid lightning
and then about a 20 percent chance as we
get through the rest of the week each
day with those hot triple digits
greater chances for thunderstorms this
weekend as we see more energy come our
way
so saturday and sunday please make some
indoor plans
to be safe with temperatures near 100